ok so let
me start with d story again so i was
attending tu layers up tu me hd and
devar dat it have it's colleague where finding
let's of ideal in next
files and vile devar are on reasons in
sml errors one of de in
Date they found out has this followers so next there were
tags like open tags
and close tags and in an wellexcel you bill
expect date this open tags and close
tags must match you in a well form they so per example if you
open this title tag you
Close D Title IF You Open D Authors Date You Have Too
Close Tag Open D Publication Tag
You Have Too Close D Publication Tax So
This Is An Example Of And SML
Document Date Is Valid But Her Is An Example Where This Is Not
Happening And If This
Kid of error happens when SML
document has a very dracony or way of
handling errors and which this SML base
technology is like experts access full de
two process de data so dat was melly happening at
act 180 but this kid of and is nothing
special about 80  So there were
studies in and every it's showing tu now dem and one
of dem from Google where they found out date
one of de major how of
exemplars are kid of dependent on de way
and one of de major how of excellent de
miss match between opening  And ending text
so and it's really not possible tu debarge this answer
is this sml file cent tu they
really really big and this is really not possible tu debut these
sml files
manual so they want you have some kid of way
tu incorporate automatic way of correct
prepaying  d sectional files and one
possible wait you can provide repair so on example if you see this
document
this is an invalid sml file so d tags and
note well formed so what you can do you can just
delete this authors tag and date
mix d document well formed  So I just
making a minimal kid of edit just deleting
one of the D tags and doing this
minimal edit repair your finding a well
form document so IF one way of
provisioning repairs when the SML
document is not well form so provided a
minimal edit repair and  It Was Found
Date This Kid Of Minimal Edit Repairs
Actually Perform Pretty Well So This Is De Do
Showing De
Closer It's Butter So This Part Of Match Butter
Give Some Of De Greeting
[Music]
Per This Kid Of Adults In HTML
Document
So What Has Grammar  What do you do about this
SML data format it can be
represented by context free
grammar like on my language is like
Cortex programs and this kind of
SML tax sequence date they are looking for can be described
by a class of
context free grammar thoughts  Non Aaj
DC Language
And When You Are Saying They Are One Too This So
An ValueExcel Document Bill Be A Member
Of Date Grammar Of Date Formal Grammar And
Context Free Language And When They Are
Saying There Errors In Next M Document
Which Excel Tax Sequence What Is  Happening
date it is not
it so it is not following d rules of date
grammar and they have you make minimal edit
minimal edit repairs they want you insert
delete and substitute aaj minimal s possible
you make it a valid member of d grammar
so tha ho it which started  Like playing
with grams
and if you're not like heaven handled me
in action sml files so you're not
ever of date kid of weather be have
spencer time like thinking about ho are in
sequence ford odd in general other
secondary structure like and computational
Biology About Second There Is Structures
N Different Identity And Its Sequence And I Be Your
Favorite Problem Is Like Which
Player Shortest Lesson And You Just Love You Do
Matrix Multiplication So Whatever They Are Objective So It Jump
Be Diverse But You
N Saint You Bill See Date  Jo these problems are very very
welcome actor ok so tu was dat
goal so let me no define what you kal
d language edit distance
so what is language tu very
welcome you just want
tu no weather d string
belongs to you d camera note weather you can
fast  D String According To D Rules
Of D Cruise Right And Author Problem Is
Street Distance Where You Are Give Us Tu
String
And You Want You Make Minimal Edit On D
Input String Session Relation And
Substitution You Make It Say Today D Defense
String One From Bill Wickham  D difference
spring so d edit distance tree so
language
passing context free grammar day after tomorrow and
string edit distance so every instance of
n single reference frame you have n set of
strings and you are living n input stream
and you want you find again a d minimum
edit  On d input string data
required you make it a valid member of
d grammar
so in d string edit distance you just
have single reference ring and input string
each you have n collection of strings so
dat we generalizers string edit distance
and this collection of strings is  Basically
a language found where what is grammar from
d passing problem you are asking where d
distance is zero and non zero and
every you want to find d minimum it
distance so date generalizers
and this problem [
music]
date life n model which is specified by
But m language which ur data feed d model and this
question appears in different
areas so they are bill motivated to study this problem from
d data quality of view from
managing like errors in SML data
but it appears and on compiler option
designing error correcting
Computational Language Please Do What You Want
These Problems Which Are
Best On Local B Strategies On
Different Classes Of Grammar Where There Is General Did
n't Come With Other Kid's Theoretical
Fiberforce Guarantee
So They Want You Have The Way You Want You Design Is
Fast Algorithmic Where It's Either Exact
And Approximate On Language Editor
Problem Date Bill  Rain Faster Den and Give
Date Bill B D Dynamic Programming
So I Bill Come Tu D General Questions of Like
Answering This Question General Language
Editor Distance But Before Date Leaves Look
Back Tu D Problem Date Way Start It
With SML Tag Bill Playing Which Can Way
cast today n dc language edit distance
problem
so what is diet language if d
language of well balance balance so you have
a string of parentheses you want you check
weather date parents this string is well
balance and note provide d most scene d
scene please kid off  Questions in Alcohol
Date You Encounter Like in First Tag Best
Friend
So Her This Open Latest Indicate Open
Paranthesis Sorry D Capital Letters Indicate
Open Paranthesis and Small Letter Syndicate
Close Paranthesis So IF You Get This
Capital B Matrix Mall Way Capital C
Matches Small C and Capital  A matches with
small so this is well balances well font but
every capital b country and
matrix is ​​mall so it is not well
danist
and this diet language is a fundamental
cortex free grammar it
plays an important role in the development of formal
Language Theory And It's Also Non Date A
Non Deterministic Version Of DK Language Has
D Hardest CNG
Soup Probably You Can See D Relation Between
Diet Language On SML Prepping Right
In
So It's Also Non Date Other Kid Of Context
In Grammar It Can Be There Is N You  Can
define home and fencing kindle between a
diet language and an from an on
deterministic pressure language and a diet
language and intersection of a regular
language OK
so I think you can see the valence between
externally recurring and I
can define it distance because of external recurring  You have
D tax sequence which has a which are
like open parentheses and closed
parentheses in a validex sequence they must be
well form well balance but sometimes
it is not and thoughts when it is derived from
DK language and they want
you do they want you make  Minimum number of
address on d on d in parentheses they want you
insert daily it and substitute aaj minimum
s possible you make it well balance
andar dhan a society document dewar mein aadhaar
applications because in programming
language like program control
structures if u open and if fl u
HAVE YOU COME OUT OF D IF YOU OPEN A
FOLLOWER THEY HAVE YOU COME OUT OF D FOLLOW YOU SO
DIET LANGUAGE APPEARS AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
EXEMPLARY IN BIOLOGICAL STRUCTURE PROTECTION IN ALLENIFY FALLING YOU BILL HAVE YOU DIES
BASE NUCLEAR TYPE PAIRS THEY MAST MATCH
I SAID DATE  Language Edit Distance Is A
Generalization Of String Edit
Distance
And It's Not Very Difficult You See Science You
Have You Strings Yes And T What You Jump Do You Can Take This Is You Can
Replace This By
Capital Letters Indicating There Open
Parantheses You Can Take D Other  string you just
leave n like reverse it and happen you
compute d the get it distance over this
very simple
sequence of open paranthesis follows in n
single sequence of close
but every you have n very simple type of
directory one single sequence of open
paranthesis follows by  One single sequence
of close
matching adjustment between pairs of like
sequences and they are jumped by long range
matching so where else in screening comes in
distance you can solve it in
quadratic time using dynamic
programming distance
so what do you get what is your
result
so  i mean result is near time and running
time on the credit distance
engine ulti small if you don't like it
so every is d other
statement which is rarely near time and give
approximate factor of people the times gone by were
you in is d approx best approx
Factor non on string edit distance
date runs in similar time so
same d result so
basically they get in near linear time up
polytech approx so just d dr of the
factor over d string edit distance
problem ok
so
i bill tel you know this linear near liner
time the get it distance but just a fu
related work so there is a huge
literature on the deck language of
course and formal method in programming
language is computational biology film
note going there so from theoretical
computer science side it has bin studies
Cute Velvet D Space Complexity of Deque
Language Studies Cute Well There Like Old
Papers by Nancy Lipton and Jazz Time and
More Recent Work in D Recognition of Deque
Language in D Streaming Setting It is
Also Be in Study It Within D Property
Testing Framework
and Subscribe Too  Our Work I'm Mean
Actors And Virginia They Have Shown Conditional Lower
Bounce On The Get It Distance And Give D
Related Problem Rana Folding Let
Me Know You Try Explain D Al Go It
Band Door
Simple The Is
D Optimum Amended Distance And Give
D First Define Minute  WELL BING IT DR
D APPROX FACTOR TOU ORDER OF G I
BILL TELL YOU WHAT IS LE DEN EQUAL T U T AND
GIVE D SECOND WE FIND MET WE BILL HAVE AN
EXPONENTIAL IMPROVEMENT AND BILL GIVE YOU
D FACTOR DATE YOU ARE LOOKING AT D ORDER
OF PEOPLE  C and this is this mean implemented on
way bill data sets and also this white
birds represent d minimum edit
distance and you can c d final compared to
d optimal performance
okay so what let's start with simple so what you do you
initial is a stack when you
c open parentheses you just
insert them into d stock when you c close
parentheses you try to match it greedy live
with d top of d stock if you can match
it it is just magic but if you can not
matching you just toss a coin you just
Ann Cuckoo and Very Call Probability of Either
Delete This So Every Way and Capital C They Don't
Match They Are Equal Tu Your Probability of
Either You Bill Delete Capital C and You Bill
Delete Small B Back Set Okay So Every Way Can See They Don't
Match You  Toss a coin baby you
decide delete capital C give they give
match after date be and be they don't maths second
delete me be the after date way and they
give match every and a they match and so what I would do if you have something
Something left on d
string but this date is from this you bill
delete d symbols from d string and if
d string is empty there are single the
need then singles from this time so
this is very simple garden
s guarantee on this kid of very simple random
Relationship because of
thoughts not really difficult you follow
d high level idea there
exists on optimal stag best
algorithm so every only alike delicious and because of
this per dedicated distance is kid
of d hardest edit operation you handle if you can
handle delicious you already get n
you  N approx so it's ok so life we ​​are we are trying to achieve
n poly of n
approximation so this is fine so there exists
on optimal stag
ordering which also performs exactly as
a d random delicious so it bill insert
d open parent this is in d  State It
Bill Look At D Close Paranthesis It
Bill Match It Bill Really But I'm When It Cannot Match
D Difference Is D
Optical Know Which One You Delete So Her It Know It Has
You Delete Capital C But They're Real
D Random Delicious And No So  It takes a coin alum
delete capital C date can do right
think in date how it remand
synchronized with out but it may also
delete small b and in date how it is made a
color decision so it yards away from opt right
and once it yards  Come from the morfth
place where random delicious bill get
started jump be very different from where the
actual optimal alger the wood has gone
straight and flour separation but what you can show is the
first of which at every step when random
delicious and where you make an  Decision One
of D Decision is Kind of Correct If You Take It Close to
Some Optimal
State and You Can Take It
So date analog help us tu map it this
process of deleting symbols wide random delicious
tu award dimension and random non
s camera
with certain amount of dollars
and they wood show date de number of delicious
performed in this random delicious process is
bonded in de number of  Status taken
by d gambler tu get read start's
dollar the
note b loss so date jump b fine but
jump just like that c date it's
waiting d weather and look very good
compared tu d white bird and they want tu
make match improvement so late c  D
first defined so for D first refined
every it is on D question you gas so you have a
very simple you just
have one sequence of open paranthesis
follows by one sequence of closed
paranthesis so for this kid of simple instance what bill you do
bill you find
So you can what you can do you can create
two
lower cases and
basically and do a spring edit distance
computation and that work because an optimal
algorithm on every deck edit distance compare the
sequence of close
parentheses with this sequence of open parents and they no date
Because they just have a single blogs so
late yesterday it up
block and finding D sequence it is very
difficult to find D appropriate sequence
of open bracket which are compared against
H block of closed bracket when
you have two full blogs per example every
might look at these
Fast Comment Compare This Fast Block Of
Close Panel This Is Only A Subset Of D
Fast Block Of Open Parents
Give Compare This Fast Second Block Of
Closetination But D Question
So Ho Can You Identify This Sequence And The
Answer Is Let Us Random Delicious Against
Random Relationship But  No this time
note you do d perform d edit but you find
this equation doing random whatever random relation is doing and
bill check what on d sim what on d
open bracket dates are compared against d
first block of close bracket by d random
delicious process and  From date u
bill extract and approximate sequence
compared tu d first sequence of optimum
and similarly let u bill move tu d second
block u bill check water d open paranthesis
which are compared by this random delicious
and from date u bill approximate d
second sequence so on
And the same doing this apparent factor comes dr
tu have
seen where d number of block and the same
processing you can show dat d number
of block is li give the optimum distance
so tha life improvement from d tu so ok but
they and style not happy
They want you have further improvement from
order of ji you order of low ji so every is
de finally fine and so you know order you
understand de finally fine and you have you understand where from this
factor jin aparoksh is coming well where
from is it coming  So this is
d sequence date d sequential random
dilation process detect sorry this is d
optimum sequence and this of d
frequency date frequency process
detect so you are obviously make some errors
so when detecting d fast sequence what
it did mistakenly grabbed one
single from d second  Sequence too
SO IF YOU HAVE YOU GET
ANYTHING BUT GIVE
APPROX YOU HAVE YOU FIND AN WAY YOU STOP THIS ERROR PROPAGATION YOU HAVE YOU
CUP ERRORS LOCAL
AND YOU DO DATE WHAT THEY DO IS SO
PERFORM INSTEAD OF
SEQUENTIAL RANDOM DAILY PERFECT PARALLEL
RANDOM DELICIOUS INSIGHT H BLOCK  Separately
So Date Vator Errors Happen In One Block It
Country Not Affect D Errors Like Vator
They Bill Happen In D Other Blogs So Every It Is
D Second Sequence Date Was Detected
In Sequential Random Delicious Process
So You Can See Date There Are N Symbols From
Every  There are symbols from d second block
today well today d fast block and that same it gap
three of d symbols which should have belonged to
d third sequence right
so every when you are doing this parallel random
delicious and process so you want allowed date so
they  Bill Has A Random Delicious Process
Only Going Into The Block Too And It Bill Stops
Whenever It Tricks You Out Of The Block Too
Extract Aaj Small
Sequence From Date
Okay So Obviously What Would Happen What Cold Happened There Are Some
Symbols Which
Bill Rum Process In This When You Are Doing This
Parallel Randomization And You Have You
Process
More Suitable Per Parallel Inflammation D
Approx Factor Goes Dr From Order  Of course the
performance is pretty well so this is a
blue part first you welcome so this is which is about the
created
distance which dynamic programming gives a
cubic surrounding time and you can get it
near linear time with
an approximation question  This is what can
you do about D general language
so on date you jump not with date lucky date you can not get
Dr D running time from
cubic you near Indian and because and on
day after tomorrow they don't know like it's not possible you
get a running time butter  Than we you d omega where omega is
d fast matrix
multiplied like exponent of first
matrix multiplication what ever be your approx
factor b is
not possible you have other running time butter
give in the you omega and with
multiplicative approx so what you can
help on this  D in tu d omega running time
and what you show date in
interviews which phone plus mines approx and
d se technique and cups one plus mines your
and they also get d first of cubic
algorithm on related problem maximum likelihood day
after tomorrow of stock so let me just
Briefly tell you what what you cast
n devar is so insta context free
grams you have these rules but know this rule sir
associated with some condition probability and you
want you fan life n stream you want you
find d
passing of d string date has n maximum
Probability
Second This Problem You Can Solve It in
Cubic Time And There Has Been So
This There Is No Progress And Afternoon Everyone else's Tomorrow Gotedar
Think First Programmer Passing I
D Exact On Approximate Per Years
And This Problem
Date Life D Probabilistic Generative Model What Is
It D  Most Likely Explanation
Per Your Observed Data and This Question Money
Money Devils Application
Natural Language Processing in General K of
Model Mini
Topic
Modeling Biological Structure
and Per D Fan Per This Problem I Go
So I'm Always Talking About Aparoks Per
Date Because IF You Fool IF  You try tu
computer exact alcohol dam per sis to
caustic contrix programer per singh they
jump show date problem is today hard today wait a
psp so you can not get and exact sub
tv tomorrow go demandless you have twenty your
balance unless you have getting per jo  D
Different Problems
So What About A Language Tu Exact
Computation Of Language Its
Distance So Let Me Come Tu Date
Of D Talk But Before Date Let Me
Tell You Briefly About D Main Concepts Behind The Cent Tu D Omegle Go Us On
Language Programming
And This  In this life yahoo and fitness and in
1972 so what de date so you have de rules
per de context free grammar you have some additional
rules
tu witch and called error producing rules
so de bill lao you tu handle in session and
substitution errors so per example  Every
non terminal art produces a in de
grammar but no you allowed this non terminal
art also produces b s well dat
terminal but no this is like substitution so they are
loving substitution error but when you have given this rule
you have paid up
Penalty so air substituting one so gas jivan you have jivan
today score of one you use this
production
be in de grammar but you bill love you you
produce it today well and devar it en score
on it devar is en penalty per it so no
de language  It is distance problem just becomes like you have tu pass according to this
augmented grammar and you want tu
date has minimum total score
dynamic programming so just tu find out
d answer par d substance i tu k u look at
all possible sub divisions so IF  D stream
steps tu i tu ke mines one its jump b passed starting
from d non
terminal with d score of
Substantive I you
from D non terminal C because there is a
production which is C yards you and B so
from A and B you did you C and D score
of
Bill b d minimum of d sum of
express
looking aate jo possible breakpoint so date
bill b order of n time and this is n
square size dynamic programming table
so what jo and cup running time
view d's computation of dynamic
program
so what ho do you define  This i special
matrix product so no h entry of d
matrix is ​​n collection of tu plus of d
form non terminal and score just significant
date d substantive i tu cake
and b pass from a with d score of x
and when you are multiply by a  Tu b
u again jain with c because devar is this
production rules c gaz tu and b and from x
and a u generate
Do you bill start with matrix
very increase on d single entries
industry and you bill cup on multiplying
and compute d transitive closure and
matrix and date what ever d increase you
bill have bill b d from today what you have
computer from d dynamic program it what
Do Multiple
OK So Know If This Alternate View Point Has So
Help Us You Design Fast And Garden So
Devour Are You Challenge Date We Need You
Address Right So One Is Can We Compute H
Matrix Product First And D Second Is We Can
Compute D Transitive Closure
Faster per de complete matrix product
first so this special product date they have they can they do you say you
mean plus matrix
product computation and brother this this
breakfast can be
computer in little let thank
you other trolley everyone's they can go again so what
you  Do So You Do Aproksh So D Good
Think Is That There Exist Nice Aproksh
I Bill Go It By Sweet Per Computing
Mean Plus Matrix Product In Order You Make A
Time
So Thoughts N Good News What About D
Transitive Closure Computation in General
Computer Is Isi So  You just take a
matrix you cup on multiply like
take d square and take power and so on so just
login multiplication what
happens is not d how every because
this matrix product is very strange so it's not
associates so you
Don't have any other kid of flexibility date you can't get a
transitive closure it's too
square in the matrix login
times so if you have a long part
three if you look it's so every word are four
symbols but you can't get a passing
information on  This Forcing Bulb Jack By Just
Looking Ate D Passing Information Of
D Prefix Of Length Tu And Suffix Of
Length Tu If There Is A Long Part Three You Have
Tu Multiply D Matrix In
Time And What Das Date Mean It Means D
Transitive Closure Computer Long Time  And
second and smaller of approx so you are
trying tu us approx algorithm on every
product but and
h multiplication times
so what are the remedies so first of which per
time required tu computer
leslie valiant from 1978 am show date and
andar this kid of non  Associative product
you can computer in almost no time today a
single product computer
approach but there are many things you do it on overlapping some
matrices so you can give them
values ​​transitive closure computation the
problem is
and was d transitive closure time bill b
less  N matrix product computation
but because of this overlap in computer
you can this decent handle d and propagation
how what
and if ur clever it bill pro
forget list in your silent times if you want us
valence method and want
us d uprok par me  Plus Product
Computation
Date They Have N Wait Wait Bonded Me
Sum Art Give You Can Have Running Time Of
Order To D Omega This Is D Old Result
Date Country Note Giving Other Good Approximate But What
They Jump Show Date And Complete D Single
Matrix Multiplication Is K  IF Number
of Distinct Scores So You Have Every
Product Every Entry of D Product
Remember Is N Non Terminal Inside Scope
Right So IF D Single Matrix Product
Competition Is K IF D Number of Dusting
Set Score
So IF There Are Distinct Scores What They
Jump Do They  They jump create art natural
numbers in d range of want tu ask
square using this contraction from me
little number
sequence
date other foot had distinct some and let them can
him d al go us allom girl in
marker let you get a running time with in
Order Of
Score Tu One Of This Tu Values ​​With
Appropriate Probability So Date D Number
Of Distance During
Multiplication And Note Tu Me When
Bill Us This Season Sequence
Construction And Multiply Fast
And This Probability So Date Event Per
Long Part Three On Expectation D
Score Of D Fast Treatment  But more
important D variance is brown dead so
you can bound D variance and on the other you can give
and estimate estimated cost which is very close to
D opticals and this also gives approx I go against
weighted APSP and other distance
computations
and D similar techniques  Gives Also Near
Optimal Algoring First Orchestra
Contacts Free Grammar Passing With Order
Of Interview About Your
Contacts From Today I Said It's A
PSP Hard What About Language And
It's Distance So This Is A Problem Date
Kid Of Travel Me Poet Update
Shaun Date You Fool Only Aloud  In fashion give
computing exact language problem
so obviously given leads to de question like what happens to
language it it
distance when only allow insertions which there it
in session deletion and substitution there is
n good reason same they jump note find n
same i jump note  Find d condition alloy
about when they are alloy which date its
and give you d excellent opportunity of
collaboration provided by d sim
institute so they no have n
sabki bhi do tomorrow par language edit
distance problem
complete exactly
so what are d mean on history  The idea in D
is date IF you follow D fame every its
computing mean class so you reduce
D special product competition you mean plus
product competition and in date reduction IF you
look at D entries subsequent entries
in D rows are in D columns they have N  Nice bonded
difference
property they jump and give as your also galing par me
plus product computer also leads
you have other folding because
it is special how and also problem mean plus
convolution without using theorem
ok
no date SML repairing which is equivalent too given
distance because you have
In tu de omega lower bound
dose and de top stock our passing
language it is distance between session they
light together with APSP in de question is
where ten language it is distance
line so no analysis given is a natural
barrier of interview tu point five so it
Like Her What Is This Life of Me Here Like Where Is
This What Is This Actual
Complexity of Language
Editor Directions So Ho Do You Design So It Would Be
Really Interesting You Design
Practical Garden Per Language Problem
Date Ten Notes Her Matrix Multiplication
and Per Date Way  Have you some kid of additive indirect influence your
contacts learning d
probability of d experience can you
design butter algorithms on other widely use
classes of language
d techniques from d diet distance
can they helpful here on regular language
in computer biology topic modeling
extra so for  Language and it
distance problem we are able to beat
dynamic programming because it has a
specific structure so d more jain well
questions like what fracture in a problem dat alo us tu be
new dynamic
programming and ho uproksh night help in
d process thank you
[appreciation  ]
Sir
sit with you
really really match butter give what it is
protected by d I go it
and this sequential land of
delicious process dat already ten very very well so
something so you n actually give ten butter
d farewell and delicious process and d
experiment
I think
Constant Bill Be Like This
Program Right Answer Getting Constant
In India
And They Are Recent Like Just Yesterday I Was
Talking With Card And They Have A Nice
Reduction With Shows Date If
You Consider String Edit Distance Too A Very Simple Kid Of I Night
Automatic Just Change  So you have other kid
regular language other kid of finiteness
automatic give computing distant jump
show some lower bounce on uprokash and
witch it very very fast
[praise]